it's been a long time since we came to
Lordran in the years since we fought
millions of battles together we've told
stories of gods and men and most
importantly we know how it ends
not with fire as Gwyn hoped nor with the
abyss as Guin feared it ends with ash a
painted world and a Dark Soul man was
born from the dark a soul that is
kindled flickers dwindles and dies in
the shadow of his gods the human form is
fragile and death comes quickly that the
spirit was strong and it clings to life
like only a mortal can so in a way man
was not designed to become Undead fear
of death is what lets us live take that
away and humanity becomes harder to hold
on to without humanity you could become
more hollow than man yet hollow who
would die for something has nothing to
fear for death simply becomes the
stepping stone to his goal
five years ago we told nine undead
stories one of the strongest man ever to
make it to an Orlando who simply fell
from its rafters another of a sorcerer
in pursuit of great knowledge who was
undone by the secrets he found for some
treasures are not meant for men and
besides even if you find the most
powerful weapon in the world there's no
reason to think you can save those you
love mankind will never escape the curse
of the gods so why not put your faith in
them perhaps if we offer up our humanity
we may receive their love in return
but no there was never any hope of that
was there these were the stories of
fools who dared to believe in something
greater hoping against hope that their
final acts could have changed fate
regrettably I have failed in my mission
but perhaps you can keep the torch lid
there is an old saying in my family
thou who art undead art chosen when dine
exodus from the undead asylum maketh
pilgrimage to the land of ancient Lords
when thou ringeth the bell of awakening
the fate of the undead thou shalt know
if you fall down seven times
stand up eight that was the cry of the
undead all those years ago and for the
most part theirs were the stories we
told but it's not just the undead who
have stories worth telling for in the
years since we've learned more about
their Lords than ever before there are
five stories I want to bring to you the
first is the tale of a chaotic
civilization doomed to fade another of a
lonely Lord who lost his domain of death
to gods and men and they could think of
at least one who would have preferred
death to the alternative there's the
story of a soul that persisted
throughout the ages
and of course the tale of the fearful
God that started it all these are the
stories that enthralled millions of us
for years and it's a privilege to bring
them to you one last time
prepare to cry
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]